it's been three years since we got a new  Pikmin game but now we're getting an  even tinier version of the little  minions I'm Tony and this is your  portable game spot news update Pikmin is  coming to the 3ds and it's trading the  top-down view for a side-scroller Oh  Lamar will still command a squad of red  blue yellow and other Pikmin but now  you'll toss them toward important  objects by tapping on the touchscreen  Pikmin still have the same properties  like red being immune to fire and blue  breathing underwater but the 2d plane  totally changes how you use them all in  all it looks to be more puzzle focus  than its console cousins Pikmin for 3ds  doesn't have an official title yet but  it's coming in 2017 Nintendo also  confirmed this summer that Pikmin for is  in development so we'll be spending  plenty of time with the little guys in  the future to keep up with all the  biggest Nintendo news you're already in  the right place  you